i don't i mean i don't think women are
better than men
uh but i do think that men are worse
than women
you know we just have like i was talking
to my friend and he said his
girlfriend's mad at him i said what
happened he goes
well i guess i uh i guess i said
something and then uh
and then she got her feelings hurt it's
a weird way to phrase it she got her
feelings hurt i said something and then
she
could you more remove yourself from
responsibility
she got her feelings hurt it's like
saying yeah i shot this guy in the face
and then i guess he got himself
murdered what happened i just shot he
leaned into it i didn't know
one of you guys know this but there is
actually 72 genders now which means that
men are better than 71 genders
boys boys
[Applause]
carried away carried away
i actually went to a bar that had gender
neutral washrooms and it's kind of weird
because i'm just like taking a [ __ ] in a
girl's washroom
and there's like these 20 year old girls
looking at me like what are you doing
i'm like this is your idea 20 year old
girls
on me and then i came out and i was
telling my buddy it was kind of weird
and he goes dude this place doesn't have
gender-neutral washrooms
you just took a [ __ ] in the girl's
washroom and everyone's talking about it
i guess i'm a little more progressive
than you when i watch sports i'll be
thinking about like think about okay
okay
say say lebron james uh
changed his gender you know what i mean
okay can he stay in the nba
or because he's a woman
does he have to go to the wnba where he
will score
840 points a game
[Applause]
what does it actually mean to be equal
you know what i mean like women are
actually equal to men
then there would be no wnba would there
he would just be good enough to play in
the nba with us
or here's another idea that's gonna be
very controversial
you could shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
finally in this in milwaukee wisconsin a
man allowed his eight-year-old daughter
to take the wheel of his car and an
accident ensued
that damaged seven other cars and
injured six people
which once again proves my theory women
can't drive
like there's a lot of countries in the
world that treat women like [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up
but they got the best food
the more countries like stay in the
kitchen the better the food
comes out of the kitchen right it does
have you ever eaten food from a country
where the women are equal
get it away what is that equality
cuisine move it remove it
move safer drivers men or women well
according to a new survey 55 percent of
adults feel that women
are most responsible for minor fender
benders while 78
blame men for most fatal crashes
please note that the percentage in these
pie graphs do not add up to 100
because the math was done by a woman
for those of you hissing at that joke it
should be noted that that joke was
written by a woman
so now you don't know what the hell
they're doing
no i'm just kidding we don't hire women
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]